100 hey how's it going um this is a
compromising position behind welcome to
this video I guess this is gonna be the
beginning of the video it doesn't make a
lot of sense now but it will crush your
neck so mark what are we doing
again like I said before I have no idea
what we're doing here but uh thankfully
my pony's inflating so that's awfully
nice when isn't it a euphemism look at
the goddamn size of this thing
if this thing isn't a euphemism I don't
know what is and we're looking dark in
the forest there's a deer man I want
everyone to know about my new inside
pocket it's called my butthole it's my
dick guys it's my dick tiny teeny tiny
dick tiny [ __ ] it's a nice tail
[Music]
with this turkey penis who do you want
to kill first I guess even man blue blue
hair peas and carrots peas and carrots
peas and carrots you are gay you're gay
there's a lot of gay like all of this is
pretty gay
I mean I'm indicating but nice nope did
somebody say John Mayer your body is a
wonderland suddenly realize you're
lesbians oh all right nice pulled
dancing skills hit dry Pig Drive oh okay
I've never been to talk over what yep
talk about wonderful can't see that boy
Wow look at that giant [ __ ] you do know
you're 20 right you can stop going
through puberty at any time I started I
can't believe there's another human
that's shorter than I am wants me know
so you're a former gymnast oh so you
failed that and then decided to fail at
YouTube I just burped no music even just
music in my heart all right so um as you
can hear by the sound we just ran into a
problem
Oh peaceful silence what a wonderful
sound god this wasn't on auto white
balance little Tungus okay so we
survived the onslaught and we got a cool
shot which is really what matters right
guys one cool shot it's the [ __ ]
party room oh all the neighbors are
gonna be [ __ ] pissed
oh you're done you're done yeah yo your
conch your uncle Kunkel
your piece of conch your [ __ ]
[ __ ]
take the batteries out and it doesn't
[ __ ] stop your pieces
[Music]
baylin's good it's hard to watch it's
hard to blame no one's gonna watch this
you are that we're not listening this is
the most us watching us play my chest
with the whiteboard but wrong sides kind
of gray oh boy we can do like it cool a
nice first-person at the ball
pretend you're Ian at me I will dodge my
weakness tell my mom I told you so why
would you stand up when you die
[Music]
professional ethic you gotta drink lots
of moo moo milk
bye moo moo milk I made chocolate mocha
my chocolate milk I mean water by water
I mean Gatorade non-brand name of course
see on the field within you did nope -
sounds like a double birds do it
Tyler that's messed up high-five for
being yourself Tyler
you fancy a date with me stop it you're
too much hey Ethan what do you think I
think is our lovely creatures
I don't know goose if I could but you
know there's that goose law only one
goose per household and my mom has
already got one I can't have one of my
own so you know maybe it's the law
changes then I could get my own goods
but until then I'll just have to take
upon the streets pop Oh turkey right
foot red yeah hello everybody my name is
markiplier and welcome to the 12 days of
Christmas we got 12 days of fun coming
at you very soon mark right foot green
it's already there you idiot won't put
it on a different one oh nice me
Wolverine
left foot T Tyler's left foot
Tyler you been climbing ever warmth oh
wait
friendship meet
[Music]
it's so thick it's still being do you
feel do you feel do you you you Oh
it's time for Christmas get ready boys
and girls
Santa's coming for you write down how
you feel comfortable like that you don't
like that no Santa likes that sorry my
voice is a little gravelly I'm still a
little
but I've taken four different types of
coldness types Oh God
sorry my voice may be a little bit
gravelly but I've tailor that was a
mulligan gonna warm up on it hang on let
me stunt on there ready uh they're good
bad always always bad as it should be
hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to the eggnog alright cool
I need a haircut real bad let the
stylist come in flying in the stylist I
can still see the way the wax tip up
you're here hello everybody my name is
markiplier and welcome to the eggnog ice
bath no not that time no you'll know
you'll know okay alright got this we're
ready
I love you ah no no harm men it's all
just a goof in a gaff alright so right
now I'm going to Twitter and I want to
ask you guys Twitter Christmas Twitter
Christmas wish was Chris Twitter look
Chrissy's a good holiday move I'm saving
one for one when you get in their unit
drink
you really want me to pour it why do you
want me to pour it on so let's see mark
that was pancake batter it's very
different
the holidays are sacred sacred cut to me
[Music]
skills where you realize you're getting
better as time goes on and if you like
oh I ever do this in the future
why am I good at this I'm really good at
[Music]
shoes nice there's those kids I got in
from the Swiss Alps but these are for
baby these are my skis
I call these must foods for stirring
yeah
[Music]
about that that was amazing I know right
you amazing next me that's alright
[Music]
why did we I don't know